[Musique]
mais où aller chercher les 200 milliards
d'euros de dettes publiques du deuxième
trimestre 2020 pas les impôts sur le
revenu jean castex et emmanuel macron
l'ont dit ils n'augmenteront pas pavin
mois de la présidentielle c'est
politiquement ruineux et en plus pas
forcément efficace puisque ça ralentit
l'activité ou alors taxer certaines
grosses entreprises qui s'en sont sortis
le mieux ces derniers mois
du côté de la fraude fiscale peut être
non plus reste l'épargné et lit selon lo
fce
les français auraient accumulé 55
milliards d'euros sur les deux mois du
confinement
enfin en grande partie les plus riches
la moitié serait le fruit d'une 10 % des
français les plus aisés ont 20% des
ménages les plus modestes n'aurait même
pas réussi à mettre plus de côté
taxer l'épargné ça s'est déjà vu
l'italie en 1992 avait prélevé 0,6 pour
cent de l'epargne de ses habitants ou
chypre qui en échange d'un plan d'aidé
européen avait taxé certains dépôts
bancaires à hauteur de 47,5 pour cent
pas d'affolement toutefois pour
l'instant en tout cas le gouvernement
compte toujours sur un rebond économique
une reprise tant attendue pour redonner
la santé à une économie
mal en point
[Musique]